[Music]
trump was doing this with
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
ten times
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
look at that look at that
look at that look at that
look at that
look at that look at that
who thinks he's smarter than you
who thinks he's smarter than you why who
thinks he's smarter than you this is
is
now that we are up under our bodies
regime my bag of mangoes now cost 11.
and 99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes manga aren't mangoes like
three boxes
[Music]
is
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
president joe biden is going to be
addressing the nation momentarily
calling for action from congress on gun
safety regulations now on today's
podcast our members would have had this
what like uh i guess six hours ago oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad that is a
freaking predator right yeah on the
predatorial bonus show hours ago uh and
the full show our members have already
seen my interview with democratic
congressman jamie raskin who i would
love to see run for president someday
and raskin says
i don't know that anything's really
going to happen and he was being very
very realistic with me so um
you know let's see what joe biden says
but of course we've got to be doing
something we've got to be doing
something and so far we're doing a lot
of nothing
uh over on
trump's platform truth social truth
essential the trolling has become
outrageous for my content i've basically
just been posting a lot of my same
tweets there
and uh ninety percent of the replies are
aggressively weaponized so that's going
on
um and we're going to continue
exploring the circumstances there i do
want to say thank you we are in the
middle of a twitch level 4 hype train
and i need to thank some amazing people
including green man now subscribed 27
months i am harvey jp de beast five
subscriptions gifted by milo wilde and
pro dad build deeper shades of house 25
months
slip and shank and micro kimmy as well
as makawaka
putting us at 12 and i've only been
streaming for a minute
also thanks to sweet thang number 13
always appreciative of everybody's
support i have a few new elements on my
soundboard thanks to our loyal
soundboard technician small fuzzy moss
in terms of so i've got this glitches
um
[Music]
element i guess i would call it we have
a bunch of new glitches for your
listening pleasure take a listen to this
static
that's a big one
law and auto
if you care about law and auto that's a
big one
lice americans of all walks of life
all types of lice are welcome
uh as you know we need to make sure we
vote for the correct law markers
advising lawmakers exactly this one i
don't even know what it is and the
combat infantryman
infantropin sounds almost german
yeah and then coined during trump's
recent event over the weekend virtues
cycling virtue cycling i've actually
engaged in virtual roller skating and
it's crazy no breaks on my roller skates
it's completely out of control and then
we have this isn't really a glitch it's
just weird i have this one on my
soundboard as well now you know mike did
me on 60 minutes yeah that's that's
pretty pretty aggressive and then in my
miscellaneous where's my miscellaneous
here i've got my flushing section
where's my missile oh here's my
miscellaneous i have in addition to the
classic pillow we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines i
also have this one it's a preliminary
injunction that will get rid of the
machines once and for all once and for
all we're gonna
we're gonna be getting rid of those and
i have three marjorie taylor green clips
because bill gates wants you to eat his
fake meat that grows in a peachtree dish
a peachtree dish gazpacho police and
then lastly they probably also want to
know when you go to the bathroom and if
your bowel movements are are on time
they're on time exactly
very very important stuff there
from marjorie taylor green a couple
super chats coming in would you ever
consider making a coupon code donald
prump the problem with complicated
coupon codes
is if they're difficult to spell because
they have some pun or joke
nobody will use it that's why something
like for example
big voting 22 surrounded by
water big water yeah big voting 22 is
good because there's really only one way
to spell it
pappy says david i think nothing will
change on gun reform there's too much
money in guns that may be
that maybe
couple of other thank yous over on
twitch diboxide ryan vivi
menzin
hippie chick wolf cult thank you thank
you thank you to all of you
um up to 18 and of course of course the
coupon code obama obama still active on
my website joinpackman.com
fruit is more dangerous than rifles just
ask donald that's right
uh no fruit can be very very dangerous i
actually bought a papaya today
and you could you could really hurt
someone with it i mean no joke it's not
even ripe at this point
an unripe papaya you could do two things
with an unripe papaya make spicy thai
papaya salad
i think it's called uh
is it
some gong what's the
name oh i never forget hold on
thai papaya salad there's a specific
name for it
oh god sometime sometime
you could do two things sometime make a
sometime or
beat someone over the hell over the head
with it
those are really the only the only two
things you could do
um
i voted on a paper ballot and then fed
it into a machine can i be sued as well
i wouldn't be surprised if you could i
wouldn't be surprised all right as we
wait for joe biden i have a few
different things here oh by the way
people are mentioning yams
i've done pretty deep research about yam
uh my understanding and correct me if
i'm wrong
um
yams in the united states genuine yams
like a bonafide yam are extremely rare
and very often sweet potatoes are
mislabeled as yams can anybody in the
chat confirm that i i've read that
that sometimes you go into a grocery
store and they say with tears in their
eyes they say sir this is a yam and it's
actually just a sweet potato yams are
apparently gargantuan they have like
it's like an it has elephantitis of
sorts it's a monstrous
and uh yeah it sounds it sounds feasible
anyway could you please give a shout out
to digiblix it's her birthday yes happy
birthday the g blix absolutely
love the show david thanks for all you
do and the gift of the obama sound bite
well let's do something special
first person to sign up on my website
joinpacman.com today with the coupon
code obama gets a free item from my
online store you've got to type it
correctly incorrectly that's oh no
that's password hold on coupon code
obama
and then
glorious things happen as you can see
first person to use that today can get a
hat or a t-shirt or a hoodie
really uh really whatever you want all
right let's look at a couple of other
things here here is lauren bo bear in
her recent debate
she accuses her opponent of being a
quote illegal drug dealer selling quote
hot hemp now i have friends in the hemp
industry uh
they've never used the term hot hemp
listen to this
because he voted for an anti-police bill
but hey maybe with this
decriminalization of fentanyl maybe i'm
not understanding it completely and
there was alternative motors
there were alternative motors they had
electric motors they had hydrogen fuel
cells it was all alternative motors
yourself for selling hot hem
the crowd is laughing at her absurd
claims and she's calling for order and
the audio is toxic
she doesn't even know what she's talking
about that makes you an illegal
that's all she had to say wow whoever
was running the audio there must be
antifa
and are incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing goodbye
let me recover my ears for one second
yeah
um thank you to fipa
for the twitch prime subscription you
are number 19 today number 19. i
appreciate that
let's see what else we've got this was
pretty vile rafael edward cruz the
republican senator from texas that's the
way we say it down in mexico
um in the aftermath of this horrible
shooting in uvalde
texas
he went and played poker
he did a poker match
when you play and harvard serves on the
committee on foreign relations
sponsorship's a thing in chess yeah or
at least for for content i i want to
send a message to alexandra and just be
like
what what the hell is going on in this
thing
i have actually haven't watched this
whole thing it would be interesting if
she confronted him i have it on good
authority because um alex and andrea
have told me mama botez is a big fan of
the david pakman show so i can only
imagine
um
that the botezzes is
are not aligned with rafael cruz's
politics it would have been beautiful to
see something
insane happen some kind of brutal
takedown i doubt that they would do that
um because the only other sponsorships
only go to top players but now people
don't monetize their chess but they
monetize their viewers so how did the
netflix show change things for you had
to be like pretty huge right yeah it
basically started bringing attention
from all the main stream media sources
what netflix show did the bow testers
have
oh oh oh she must mean the chest [ __ ] oh
i okay no i i misunderstood so that was
really helpful
did you watch the queen's gambit doyle
huh did you watch the queen's gamut no
this chess show it was amazing you saw
it yeah i saw it yeah you guys saw it
yeah it's great it was amazing how
realistic was it i mean it's it was the
most accurate depiction of chess in tv
that i've ever seen before there are
obviously some things that miss like for
example if you're going to be the best
in the world you would have had to
technically start a little bit younger
um they didn't really show her
anyway ted cruz just you know a man of
the people i don't know what this thing
is i would love to play in this thing i
think i i i would mix it up if i was at
this thing it would be a great time i
don't know how i'm probably not big
enough to get invited but i would love
to play poker after dark gg poker her
origin story well senator welcome to
poker after dark it's great to have you
here do they whitewash him completely
what's your what's your poker background
like fill us in well i grew up playing
poker my grandmother taught me wow and
and so my parents would drop me off my
grandmother's house i would play and i'd
win and i'd win and i'd win
and when i was eight or nine years old i
had saved up five dollars how wholesome
which was ten weeks allowance because i
got 50 cents a week allowance and so i
came and said granny let's play for real
money so we said is this like a sir
story do you guys think this is even
real sat down played for real money
she took every penny from me
when my mom came to pick me up i was
crying tears coming down my face and
my grandmother was just laughing you
know she's irish in italian and happy to
teach your grandson a lesson well let
that serve as a warning folks
so that's pretty freaking vile i'm not
gonna lie i'm not not a big fan of that
uh but there is um there is there
there's ted cruz
thank you to sheetrock bobby for the
twitch prime subscription you're number
20. the free item from the online store
goes to david torres david torres the
first person to sign up at
joinpakman.com today with the coupon
code obama obama thank you please email
info davidpakman.com
i want to say thank you also to david
dinar
and joseph jaworski each of them david
and joseph just gifted a membership each
which we will give away if you want a
free membership just put your name down
at davidpakman.com
slash free membership also thank you to
kiara hannah
pia schultz
and juan for gifting another membership
as well that puts us at 25
and i am very very appreciative of
everybody supporting we are standing by
here for ted cru for ted cruz for joe
biden
david thoughts on ethan from h3 getting
cancelled by the write for making jokes
i don't know what happened with ethan
does anybody i just haven't seen it
uh i would love to know you know we're
friendly with ethan he's been a
supporter of my work over time and
he and hassan recently gave me a
positive name check which i love
i don't know what happened though is
that graham steven from youtuber playing
with ted cruz yes it is yes it is let's
look at another clip or two here
marjorie taylor green says that some of
the most dangerous people in the u.s are
trans guys well you know how you hear
jerry nadler and the democrats and joe
biden and kamala harris and aoc and and
all these people telling you that the
most dangerous terrorists or domestic
terrorists in america are white
supremacists obviously but here's what
you need to know i think some of the
most dangerous people in america are
trans terrorists okay i don't know of
any
i mean listen i'm willing to be to be
proven wrong but
are we aware of a single transgender
domestic terrorist i can't think of one
anyway
not that i'm aware of
you know nothing i can think of
uh on air oan anchor alison steinberg
says she believes supporting ukraine is
gay which one would you like to tee up
first would you like to go off on mr
obama and get your take on that or just
the insanity of the lgbt community
adding the ukraine flag we stand with
ukraine even though um
same-sex marriage is illegal in that
entire country i mean i think you nailed
it with ukraine virtue signaling and
it's the definition if you open the
dictionary to virtue signaling you would
see that image right there that is just
ridiculous on so many levels and i mean
i don't know what ukraine has to do with
sexuality if the lgbtq plus crew is
trying to indicate that supporting
ukraine is gay i might be uh in
agreeance with them there just kidding
she's in agreements agreements
watch out
in trouble they're gonna come for you
out but i mean it's ridiculous
supporting ukraine is gay i don't even
understand what what the hell is being
discussed i mean it's just it's bizarre
bizarre bizarre stuff
um child ted cruz getting obliterated
and owned by his own grandmother is
probably a fake story but just like the
p-tape i will continue to believe it
very well said steven thank you
poker podcasts and fancy sushi dinners
ted cruz has an awful lot of time to not
do his job also any nba finals
predictions sir well
um i am
uh
i am supporting the boston celtics
the um great pla basically
new york city boston bars the best
places to watch
boston sports in new york city i would
say are legends okay maybe
but professor toms that's th like as in
tom hartman it's not tom hartman's bar
but it's called professor toms
and uh it's the it's the best
combination of boston sports and great
bar food
the potato wedges folks you can't beat
them
my prediction is great potato wedges
and i'm going for the celtics
i'm going for the celtics what else can
i do obviously i've got to do it
we must do it alex jones interviewed
mike tyson i haven't watched it yet but
let's just see a few minutes bring his
tobacco with him thank you sir
that is a magic moment great tobacco
magic tobacco
thank you sir the time are you married i
am tell me something about your family
did they worry do you worry about your
kids that's all who's on whose show
right now by the way yeah if i have
worries about them yeah
what's your view
on
what's currently happening with the
russian situation
i think it started out as a war for
finance
and so many of us got involved because
of the humanity of it and it became a
war of humanity because so many people
got involved so many countries are
involved and now um
russia is really losing from public
opinion perspective and that's worse
than being hit with the nuclear bomb so
to speak at least you're dead when you
hit
the ball you gotta live with this crap
wow it's not a collaboration we
how does mike tyson you know we saw
jenna's rock globalist internationalist
trotskyite socialist shun like obama
trudeau macron and the rest of these zio
beasts
right i've been almost in the korean war
that's been going on for 60 years it
kind of has ended thanks to him
could you go there maybe a brokered
priest between putin and zielinski and
you know um could you say could you go
broke her piece
i'ma look at it like this people are not
gonna like this
and sometimes i see a hawk and he grabs
a
it's not a pigeon but it's one that's
like a robbie grabs a bird and i can
stop him from killing that bird but once
i stop him from killing that bird then
he dies his baby died so whom i'm saving
how am i right
that's how i tell my kids
that is a freaking predator right there
who's the wrong person how are you right
if you save that bird right now now he's
gonna die his baby's gonna die
something's gonna die
i think that's the real knowledge is
thinking multi steps ahead right not
only looking on one level yeah you know
pretty pretty uh
pretty interesting geopolitical analysis
there from uh from mike tyson hart hard
to argue with that
thanks to lex ho aloha oh wait no it
must be lexo aloha
michael devore and aj austin for the
twitch prime subscriptions numbers 26 27
and 28. very much appreciate that
and uh
people signing up on my website no
nobody's signing up over there that's
okay that's okay will the republicans
try another coup in 24 and how do we
prevent it actually they're going to try
it in 22.
we just have we just went over the
leaked documents from politico today
and it is it's pretty bad so i won't
rehash that
ethan's show on friday was mass reported
and he was banned from youtube for a
week and the episode was removed he
joked about bombing the nra okay well
you got yeah that you got to be really
really
careful with that
it's gay to support ukraine asked john
davis yeah it doesn't really make any
sense it's a very strange claim to make
um oh a couple other things uh my
colleague john sent me this so christian
walker is herschel walker's son okay
this is so herschel walker is that guy
that trump endorsed who's running for
senate who can barely speak he's he's
barely able to speak
and christian walker has a big tick tock
following it comes on the heels of
several high-profile mass shootings that
have killed okay hold on a second we're
not starting with that yet uh oh anyway
here let just reel real quick here's one
of his clips okay
[Music]
yeah this is what herschel walker's kid
does because i grew up wanting prince
charming
not to walk around the streets with no
clothes on at a pride festival
i grew up wanting a marriage okay
uh all right joe biden is going to be
speaking momentarily and we are going to
be carrying it live live live he is
reportedly going to call demand that
congress do something something about
gun safety regulations
and we welcome that what documents
documents from trainings done by
republicans on contesting ballots
okay here we go four with pushes for
legislation after columbine sandy hook
and parkland all falling short national
addressing up to the podium it's
listening
it's the lectern the lectern not the
podium on memorial day this past monday
jill and i visited arlington national
cemetery
as we entered those hallowed grounds
we saw rows and rows of crosses
among the rows of headstones with other
emblems of belief
honoring those who paid the ultimate
price on battlefields around the world
the day before
we visited uvalde uvalde texas
in front of robb elementary school
we stood before 21 crosses
for 19 third and fourth graders
and two teachers
on each cross a name
and nearby
a photo of each victim that jill and i
reached out to touch
innocent victims
murdered into the classroom that had
been turned into a killing field
standing there in that small town like
so many other communities across america
i couldn't help but think there are too
many other schools too many other
everyday places that have become killing
fields
battlefields here in america
we stood at such a place just 12 days
before
across from a grocery store in buffalo
new york
memorializing 10 fellow americans
a spouse a parent a grandparent a
sibling gone forever
at both places we spent hours with
hundreds of family members
who were broken
those lives will never be the same
they had one message for all of us do
something
just do something
for god's sake do something
after columbine
after sandy hook
after charleston after orlando after las
vegas
after parkland
nothing has been done
this time that can't be true
this time we must actually do something
the issue we face is one of conscience
and common sense
for so many of you at home
i want to be very clear
this is not about taking away anyone's
guns
it's about philip not about vilifying
gum on gun owners
in fact we believe we should be treating
responsible gun owners as an example of
how every gun owner should behave
i respect the
conscience
and the concerns of lawful gun owners at
the same time
the second amendment like all other
rights is not absolute
it was just it was justice scalia who
wrote and i quote
like most rights
the right
second amendment by the rights granted
by the second amendment
are not unlimited
not unlimited
and never has been
there have always been limitations on
what weapons you can own in america for
example
machine guns have been federally
regulated
for nearly 90 years
and this is still a free country
this isn't about taking to anyone's
rights right it's about protecting
children
it's about protecting families
it's about protecting whole communities
it's about protecting our freedom to go
to school
to a grocery store to a church
without being shot and killed
according to new data just released by
the center for disease control and
prevention
guns are the number one killer of
children in the united states of america
can you imagine the number one killer
more than car accidents more than cancer
over the last two decades
more school-age children have died from
guns than on-duty police officers and
active duty military combined
think about that
more kids
than on-duty cops killed by guns
more kids than soldiers killed by guns
for god's sake
how much more carnage are we willing to
accept
how many more innocent american lives
will he have specific proposals enough
enough
i know that we can't prevent every
tragedy ban doors here's what i believe
we have to do
here's what the overwhelming majority of
american people believe we must do all
right
here's what the families in buffalo
and uvalde in texas told us we must do
we need to ban assault weapons in
high-capacity magazines okay and if we
can't ban assault weapons then we should
raise the aids to purchase them both
from 18 to 21. 25.
strengthen background checks
enact safe storage law and red flag laws
repeal the immunity that protects gun
manufacturers from liability
address the mental health crisis
deep into the trauma
of gun violence and as a consequence of
that violence
these are
rational common sense measures
here's what it all means it all means
this
we should reinstate the assault women's
ban in high-capacity magazines correct
that we passed in 1994 with bipartisan
support absolutely the congress
and the support of law enforcement
no-brainer nine categories of
semi-automatic weapons were included in
that ban
like ak-47s and ar-15s
and in the ten years it was law
mass shootings went down that's true
but after republicans let the law expire
in 2004
and those weapons were allowed to be
sold again mass shootings tripled that
is technically true
a few years ago
the family of the inventor of the ar-15
said he would have been horrified
to know that his design was being used
to slaughter children
and other innocent lives instead of
being used as a military weapon in the
battlefields right as it was designed
that's who's dying for
enough
enough enough
we should limit how many rounds a weapon
can hold yep
why in god's name
should an ordinary citizen
be able to purchase an assault weapon
that holds 30 round magazines
that let mass shooters fire hundreds of
bullets in a matter of minutes
because it's my ride damage is so
devastating to uvaldi
parents had to do dna swabs to identify
the remains of their children
nine and ten-year-old children
enough
we should expand background checks
to be keep guns out of the hands of
felons fugitives and those under
restraining orders
stronger background checks are something
that the vast majority of americans
including the majority of gun owners
agree on true
i also believe the nra doesn't agree
with it safe storage laws
and personal liability for not locking
up your gun
the shooter in sandy hook
came from a home full of guns
were too easy to access
that's how he got the weapons
the weapon he used to kill his mother
and then murdered 26 people including 20
first graders
if you own a weapon you have a
responsibility to secure it
every responsible gun owner agrees
to make sure no one else can have access
to it
to lock it up
to have trigger locks
and if you don't
and something bad happens you should be
held responsible
we should also have national red flag
laws so that a parent a teacher a
counselor
can flag for a court that a child a
student a patient
is exhibiting violent tendencies
threatening classmates
not only that you shouldn't require
recommendation letters for anyone under
25 who wants to buy a gun
19 states in the district columbia have
red flag laws
the delaware law is named after my son
attorney general bo biden
fort hood texas
2009 13 dead and more than 30 injured
marjorie stoneman douglas high school in
parkland florida
2018 17 dead 17 injured
in both places countless others
suffering with invisible wounds
red flag laws could have stopped both
these shooters
he knew valde
the shooter was 17 when he asked his
sister to buy him an assault weapon
knowing he'd be denied because he was
too young to purchase one himself she
refused
but as soon as he turned 18 he purchased
two assault weapons for himself
because in texas
you can be 18 years old and buy an
assault weapon even though you can't buy
a pistol
in texas until you're 21.
if we can't ban assault weapons
as we should we must at least raise the
age to be able to purchase one to 21.
yep
25. look i know some folks will say 18
year olds can serve in the military
and fire those weapons
but that's with training and supervision
by the best trained experts in the world
don't tell me raising the age won't make
a difference enough
we should repeal the liability shield
that often protects gun manufacturers
from being sued for the death and
destruction caused by their weapons
they're the only industry in this
country that has that kind of immunity
imagine imagine if the tobacco industry
had been immune from being sued where
would be today
the gun
industry special protections are
outrageous it must end true
and let there be no mistake about the
psychological trauma that gun violence
leaves behind
imagine being that little girl that
brave little girl in uvalde
who smeared blood off her murdered
friend's body on her own face
to lie still among the corpses in her
classroom and pretend she was dead in
order to stay alive
imagine
imagine what it'd be like for her to
walk down the hallway of any school
again
imagine what it's like for children who
experience this kind of trauma every day
in school in the streets and communities
all across america
imagine what it's like for so many
parents to hug their children goodbye in
the morning not sure whether they'll
come back home
unfortunately too many people
don't have to imagine that at all
even before the pandemic
young people were already hurting
there's a serious use mental health
crisis in this country
we have to do something about it
that's why mental health is the heart of
my unity agenda that i laid out in the
state of union address this year it's
what republicans claim to want
counselors more school nurses
more mental health services for students
and for teachers more people
volunteering as mentors to help young
people succeed
more privacy protection and resources to
keep kids safe from the harms of social
media
this unity agenda
won't fully heal the wounded souls but
it will help
it matters
i just told you what i do
the question now is what will the
congress do
the house of representatives already
passed key measures we need
expanding background checks to cover
nearly all gun sales including at gun
shows and online sales
getting rid of the loophole allows the
gun sale to go through after three
business days even if the background
check has not been completed
and the house is planning even more
action next week imagine arguing that in
some cases there shouldn't be a
background check it's insane it's a
sickness raising the age to buy an
assault weapon to 21
federal red flag law
codifying my ban on ghost guns that
don't have serial numbers and can't be
traced
and tougher laws to prevent gun
trafficking and straw purchases
this time
we have to take the time
to do something and this time
it's time for the senate to do something
yes but as we know
in order to get anything done in the
senate we need a minimum of 10
republican senators yep
i support the bipartisan efforts that
include small group of democrats and
republican senators trying to find a way
but my god
the fact that the majority of the senate
republicans
don't want any of these proposals even
to be debated
or come up for a vote
i find unconscionable
we can't fail the american people again
are there 10 that would go with this do
you guys think just over a week ago
there have been 20 other mass shootings
in america yep each with four or more
people killed or injured
including yesterday
at a hospital in tulsa oklahoma covered
it a shooter deliberately targeted a
surgeon
using an assault weapon he bought just a
few hours before his rampage
that left the surgeon
another doctor
receptionist and a patient
dead and many more injured
that doesn't count the carnage we see
every single day
it doesn't make the headlines
i've been in this fight for a long time
i know how hard it is
but i'll never give up
and if congress fails
i believe this time a majority of the
american people won't give up either
i believe the majority of you will act
to turn your outrage into making this
issue central to your vote
enough enough enough
over the next 17 days the families in
uvalde will continue burying their dead
it will take that long in part because
it's a town where everyone knows
everyone
and day by day they will honor each one
they lost
jill and i met with the owner and staff
for the funeral home as being strong
strong strong strong to take care of
their own
and the people of uvalde
mourn
as they do over the next 17 days
what will we be doing as a nation
jill and i met with the sister of the
teacher who was murdered and whose
husband died of a heart attack two days
later
leaving behind four beautiful
unbelievable children
all now orphaned
a sister asked us
what could she say what could she tell
her nieces and nephews
it's the most heartbreaking moment just
so people know the tulsa shooting from
yesterday isn't even the most recent
mass shooting just a couple hours ago
there was one in a cemetery in wisconsin
with multiple victims after visiting
school
we attended mass at sacred heart
catholic church with father eddie
in the pews families and friends held
each other
tightly
as archbishop gustavo spoke
he asked the children in attendance to
come up on the altar and sit in the
altar with him
as he spoke
there wasn't enough room so mom and her
young son sat next to jill and me in the
first pew
and as we left the church
a grandmother who had just lost her
granddaughter
passed me a handwritten letter
it read
quote erase the invisible line that is
dividing our nation
come up with a solution
and fix what's broken
and make the changes that are necessary
to prevent this from happening again end
of quote
my fellow americans enough
enough it's time for each of us to do
our part
it's time to act
for the children we've lost
the children we can save
for the nation we love
let's hear the call and the cry let's
meet the moment let us finally do
something
god bless the families who are hurting
god bless you all
from him based on the 91st psalm sung in
my church
may he raise you up on eagle's wings
and bear you on the breath of dawn
make you to shine like the sun
and hold you
in the palm of his hand
that's my prayer for all of you
god bless you
there is president joe biden not taking
questions today today calling for a
number of the same things i called for
last week but not going nearly far
enough that's for sure uh but certainly
um
uh making some of those uh making some
of those calls now the house of
representatives per nancy pelosi
uh will be
uh voting
on an assault weapons ban
it will likely pass the house
the question is can you find 10
republican senators willing to vote for
that uh in the senate
and the answer at least right now
doesn't appear to be yes
does not appear to be yes at this point
in time
these are all empty words biden is
saying what he has to say but he knows
and we all know nothing will change
nothing will move forward in congress
all we will get is more cable news
hysteria
james says an assault weapon ban isn't
going to change anything unless they
make a real definition ar-15s kept being
sold post-ban minus mostly cosmetics
that is true
ban lobbyists
and we will ban men i mean listen
there's a lot of ideas someone actually
did say hey you know uh
it's exclusively men who are mass
shooters just banned men from having
these weapons
uh i don't think that would be
constitutional i don't think that would
be constitutional that's for sure
all right thank you everybody for
joining me we will be back tomorrow with
a new podcast
and a new bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad and we will be back with many
many more things thank you for joining
me
see everybody very soon